la ministre devant se rendre à une
réunion pour 18h se faire de ma part
c'est le ministre vous avez accepté de
venir cet après-midi de devant notre
commission pour évoquer la situation que
le pays vient de vivre il y a maintenant
plusieurs jours pour ne pas dire
plusieurs nuits
bien sûr que l'origine de l'événement
est un événement dramatique
mais en aucun cas cet événement
dramatique ne peut justifier les émeutes
qui ont eu lieu ensuite et la violence
j'allais dire la déferlante de violence
qui s'est
qui envahit le pays en tous les cas un
grand nombre de villes de villages où
l'avait rappelé aux questions
d'actualité
de toute nature y compris sur des
critères que nous n'avons pas l'habitude
d'avoir c'est-à-dire des villages
paisibles voire des communes paisibles
j'en connais quelques-unes qui ont été
la cible d'incendie d'automobile ou de
bâtiments ou de tirs de mortier
les images de télévision
ont montré la violence avec laquelle
cette situation a été a eu lieu vous
avez mobilisé beaucoup de personnels de
police bien sûr
les pompiers ont été mobilisés les
magistrats vous l'avez cela a été
rappelé ont été aussi mobilisés pour
apporter une réponse pénale rapide
mais il n'empêche que sur le fond les
questions demeure aujourd'hui si la
situation est apaisée nous devons sans
doute vous en féliciter il n'en demeure
pas moins que on s'interroge tous de
savoir pour combien de temps
et on s'interroge tous pour savoir quel
remède demain
ce que nous partageons comme constat et
c'est là-dessus que nous souhaiterions
vous entendre c'est qu'en réalité
mairie bibliothèque espace public
lieu communal au lieu d’état voire
tribunaux ont été attaqués incendiés y
compris la maison d'arrêt de Fresnes
en réalité on se rend compte aujourd'hui
que c'est la République
c'est l'autorité qui est attaquée d'une
façon générale
les événements d'hier au tribunal
judiciaire de Lyon à l'occasion de
l'audience qui devait juger les
personnes qui ont été arrêtées et
renvoyés devant le tribunal le fait que
cette audience ait été suspendue parce
que des militants
du dragon chez étaient présents ont
perturbait l'audience en insultant
d'ailleurs la police dans un lieu de
justice
sont autant d'éléments qui nous
interrogent sur la suite des événements
sur les motivations réelles des voyous
délinquants ou criminels
je ne parle même pas des agressions
portées à l'égard des élus bien sûr
les événements récents concernant le
maire de la commune de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses mais je rappelle quand
même de l'oublions pas trop vite le
maire de Saint-Brévin je rappelle madame
le Maire de Plougrescant je rappelle
beaucoup d'autres qui depuis ce système
manifesté pour dire qu'ils étaient les
victimes de violence
dans mon département amer à lui-même
était aussi
attaqué à son domicile
bref tout est dit la situation est
dramatique la réponse
policière et la remise en ordre est en
cours et vous l'avez mené et ne vous
soutenons la question de fond et de
savoir comment demain les choses
évolueront et comment nous réagirons aux
attaques contre la République mais non
cette situation nous voulons nous
explications monsieur le ministre sur
qui a fait quoi comment comprendre les
choses et essayer de déterminer la
réalité des choses car nous sommes tous
bien convaincus ici que l'ensemble des
populations des quartiers appelés de
banlieue des quartiers difficiles sont
des gens qui ont envie de vivre
tranquille
qui ont envie d'éduquer leurs enfants
qui se sont inscrits évidemment dans la
République quelle notre République
exactement et qui avec leurs moyens
essayent de évidemment vivre normalement
donc il est bien question de faire une
réflexion de fond de ne pas faire masse
de tout de s'interroger précisément sur
les causes mais de bien c'est vous qui
pouvez nous donner cette analyse voilà
Monsieur le Miss je suis déjà beaucoup
trop long il y aura sans doute des
questions de la part des collègues mais
nous avons donc je vous le rappelle mes
chers collègues une heure de temps
merci monsieur le Président comme à
chaque fois que bien sûr une commission
des lois m'invite à expliquer l'action
du gouvernement j'y réponds
favorablement je m'en excuse si vers 18h
comme je vous l'ai dit je vous demande
de quitter votre commission car je
préside d'autres régions de sécurité
puisque si la situation est calme elle
est à surveillée comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même monsieur le Président après
ces moments extrêmement difficiles
le mardi 27 juin
2023 à 8h16 avenue Frédéric et Irène
Joliot-Curie à Nanterre des effectifs de
la DOPC c'est à dire le service de
l'ordre public et de la circulation de
la préfecture de police ont voulu
procéder au contrôle d'un véhicule avec
trois individus à son bord qui
circulaient manifestement sur une voie
de bus le conducteur de la voiture
voiture immatriculée en Pologne mais non
signalé a refusé d'obtempérer d'après le
rapport de la police nationale aux
injonctions des policiers puis est finie
par couper le contact passage François
Arago à Nanterre le conducteur a alors
manifestement subitement redémarré
le fonctionnaire de police comme tout le
monde l'a vu sur cette vidéo a fait
usage à une reprise de son arme
administrative il s'agissait d'un
policier expérimenté de 38 ans qui ne
connaissait aucune difficulté dans son
casier qu'elle avait été décorée à
plusieurs reprises il est accompagné par
un autre policier expérimenté de 40 ans
qui lui aussi ne connaissait pas de
difficultés particulière avec son
administration les véhicules a fini sa
course encastrant dans une barrière et
un poteau le conducteur qui
manifestement a été blessé au thorax
était en arrêt cardio-respiratoire les
effectifs de police qui sont arrivés en
prodigués un premier massage cardiaque
avant l'arrivée des sapeurs du Samu qui
ont pris de relais mais le conducteur
blessé a été déclaré des CD à 9h15 le
premier passager arrière toujours dans
le véhicule a été immédiatement
interpellé le deuxième passager non
identifiant des faits a pris la fuite il
a depuis chacun la vue était identifié
c'est-à-dire exprimé dans les médias il
a été contrôlé dans la nuit du samedi
1er juillet en violation de la contrôle
judiciaire sur ses horaires de sortie
est placé en rétention judiciaire il a
été remis à l'issue de la mesure à ses
civilement responsable puisque il était
comme le conducteur non majeur au moment
des faits le procureur de la République
a saisi l'inspection générale de la
police nationale et nous avons fait
pareil en administratif au même moment
et cela ont mené l'enquête vous avez vu
qu'ils ont mis en garde à vue les
policiers le policier qui a utilisé son
tir administratif au bout de 48 heures
le policier était présenté devant des
magistrats instructeurs une information
judiciaire était ouverte il a été mis en
examen et placé en détention provisoire
et n'appartient pas plus en amont de
discuter évidemment de l'enquête
judiciaire ni des suites judiciaires ce
sera évidemment
au parquet ou à la chancellerie de
communiquer à la suite évidemment de cet
événement absolument dramatique pour
lequel je crois très rapidement le
gouvernement a fait transparence et à
utiliser me semble-t-il les mots qu'il
convenait tout en rappelant que ce
policier a le droit comme toute personne
à la présomption d'innocence qui n'est
pas condamné définitivement il y a eu
une nuit celle qui a suivi immédiatement
qui aurait pu être une nuit de désordre
public et je voudrais ici dire que le
ministère de l'Intérieur s'est préparé
immédiatement au fait qu'il pouvait
avoir des manifestations
et donc il a mis en place un dispositif
d'ordre public et cette manifestation
ces manifestations n'ont pas eu lieu
puisque ce que nous avons constaté de la
première nuit ce sont des violences
urbaines à Nanterre c'est tout à fait
vrai mais dans d'autres villes de France
par effet de mimétisme de très
certainement on y reviendra et donc la
posture du ministère de l'Intérieur qui
est évidemment d'éviter un autre drame
passer à ma demande d'une position
d'ordre public à une position de lutte
contre les violences urbaines ce qui
explique à la fois la mobilisation de
moyens extrêmement différents mais aussi
la stratégie mis en place par les
préfets sous mon autorité et
singulièrement par le préfet de police
même s'il n'a pas été le seul au
rendez-vous bien sûr de cette action je
voudrais en remercier ici les préfets
les équipes de direction générale de la
police nationale la gendarmerie
nationale de la Préfecture de Police de
la DGSI qui a été également mobilisé
l'ensemble bien sûr des forces de
l'ordre y compris des sapeurs et des
prémices municipales qui ont contribué à
ce travail nous avons connu pendant ces
moments très difficiles donc je peux
compter ce moment difficile entre le 27
juin et aujourd'hui monsieur le
Président même si les deux dernières
nuits ont été extrêmement calmes 23 878
feux de voie publique et saguillèrement
des poubelles
12031 véhicules incendiés
2508 bâtiments incendiés ou dégradés
dont 273 bâtiments qui appartiennent aux
forces de l'ordre police nationale
gendarmerie ou police municipale
derrière les polices municipales ont
payé à l'autre tribu à ces attaques
inacceptables 105 mairies incendie ou
dégradées 168 écoles on fait l'objet
d'attaque quelle qu'elle soit et sur la
même période 17 atteintes aux élus ont
été recentrés par le mystère de
l'Intérieur donc bien sûr le cas de
Monsieur le Maire de l'Aïd les roses
évidemment devant une violence
extrêmement forte et devant une posture
d'interpellation
[Musique]
des gendarmes puisqu'ils ont agi dans
des conditions difficiles on les a
rappelé de leur congés on a annulé des
formations on a rappelé des missions
comme les CRS des plages pour que bien
évidemment puissent répondre à cette
problématique on a organisé des
continuités de service qui était au-delà
des horaires je serai monsieur le
Président en tant que chef
d'administration Miss à l'intérieur les
remercier symboliquement et plus que
cela évidemment pour cette mobilisation
parce que c'est leur mobilisation et
leur professionnalisme qui a permis de
rassurer les élus limiter les attaques
même s'ils ont été extrêmement
nombreuses et je veux le dire ici
augmenter un nombre d'interpellations
jamais retenu qui a permis une réponse
pénale qui je crois est forte même si je
n'ai pas tous les chiffres et que on
sait tous que la réponse pénale met du
temps après les interpellations et les
garde à vue continuez à travailler de
police judiciaire je reviendrai monsieur
le gars monsieur le Président la
Commission des lois parce que nous avons
évidemment à travailler en judiciaire
pour pouvoir interpeller dans la journée
tous ceux qui commettaient des méfaits
la nuit et ça contribuer très largement
me semble-t-il au calme j'aurais
quelques exemples à vous donner et en
confiant la police judiciaire je
voudrais dire à Monsieur Durand
peut-être avec facétie similaire en
préfigurant la réforme de la police
nationale nous avons su je crois
retrouver énormément de monde et
notamment énormément interpellé de
personnes dans la journée tellement
assigne partie des ardeurs des émeutiers
et des délinquants et nous avons su me
semble-t-il protéger quelques symboles
extrêmement forts et nous avons vu
transformer finalement ce mouvement qui
était des mouvements d'attaque
évidemment c'est un peu caricatural
parce qu'il faut regarder territoire par
territoire des attaques symboles de la
République école commissariat mairie
brigade de gendarmerie pose de police
municipale centre socio en pillage de
commerçants qui étaient la deuxième
phase si j'ose dire de cette de cette
série de nuit extrêmement extrêmement
difficile en quelques mots monsieur le
monsieur le président
45000 forces de l'ordre ont été
mobilisées l'intégralité je l'ai dit des
forces ministères de l'Intérieur
arrivent au travail des services de
renseignement une très bonne
collaboration non seulement le
commissaire de la justice mais avec les
procureurs de la République qui ont su
je crois être au rendez-vous de la
travail très important fait par la
police et par la gendarmerie mais une
sociologie qui interroge la sociologie
des délinquants des émotiers interroges
sur ces 3500 interpellations j'ai
l'occasion de le dire la moyenne d'âge
entre 17 et 18 ans elle a tendance à
augmenter un tout petit peu puisque
aujourd'hui ce que nous faisons c'est
que nous allons chercher un
interpellation des personnes qui ont été
soit par les travaux d'enquête
technologiques que chacun comprendra ici
récupérer des personnes un petit peu
plus âgées mais le dernier comptage que
j'avais c'est que la dernière la
première personne qui a été interpellée
à 11 ans et la dernière à 59 ans et que
si il y a une moyenne de 17 à 18 ans
pour ce qu'on a arrêté et que un tiers
et mineur vous aurez donc compris que
les mineurs que nous avons sont
extrêmement jeunes pour la plupart pour
la plupart d'entre eux comme j'ai dit
aux questions gouvernement monsieur le
Président nous pouvons constater par
ailleurs que à notre connaissance seule
10% des personnes que nous avons
interpellées sur de nationalités non
françaises et d'ailleurs il y a eu 40
placements en centre de rétention
administrative ce qui est peu à vous le
sur 3500 personnes interpellées je
voudrais aussi souligner que comme j'ai
dit tout à l'heure à ma connaissance 60%
des personnes que nous avons
interpellées n'ont pas de casier
judiciaire et ne sont pas connus des
services de police
cette évidemment difficile d'aller plus
au-delà de la sociologie de ces
personnes puisque après les
interpellations
ces personnes sont rentrées dans un
fichier qui s'appelle casiopée qui a
affiché judiciaire et il appartient sans
doute à monsieur le garde des sceaux
donnaient des informations dans quelques
jours je vois que c'est un peu trop tôt
pour qu'ils puissent faire sur la
composition exacte des personnes pour
que nous comprenions leur origine
géographique et des motivations
éventuelles qui les ont amenés à
commettre
jamais fait aujourd'hui monsieur le
Président la posture du ministère de
l'intérieur c'est évidemment d'être
extrêmement attentif ça repose sur trois
grands piliers le premier c'est une
présence des forces de l'ordre
extrêmement forte sur le territoire
national je constate avec vous que ni la
Corse ni les outre-mer à quelques
exceptions près un peu la Guyane un peu
la Réunion mais très en deçà de ce qu'a
fait la métropole donc il s'agit d'un
sujet exclusivement métropolitain ou
quasi exclusivement métropolitain rester
très éveillé donc pour la présence de
voies publiques et notamment la nuit
je constate également au deuxième point
que le travail que nous devons mener
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai de police
judiciaire il y a énormément
d'interpellations au moment où je vous
parle de personnes qui sont confondues
par la police technique et scientifique
nous avons particulièrement mobilisé par
les services bien sûr la préjudiciaire
qui permet de ces interpellations c'est
pour ça que les chiffres
d'interpellation augmentent qui
correspondent pas à des nuits d'émeutes
supplémentaires il correspondent au
travail de la PJ qui permet après coup
d'interpeller les personnes je pense pas
à la mairie de mons-en-barœul où je me
suis rendu 9 personnes étaient arrêtées
et vous aurez constaté qu'il s'agit de
manière extrêmement majoritaire de
mineur et évidemment ça pose un certain
nombre de problèmes qu'on se posera
sociologiquement et politiquement plus
tard mais on a vu qu'en 48 heures les
services de la police étaient capables
alors qu'un feu avait ravagé le mérite
d'interpeller les personnes donc je
remercie vraiment la grande mobilisation
des policiers qui font de la police
judiciaire et puis troisièmement il
s'agit là de lutter contre tout ce qui
contribue alors c'est pas une réponse
structurelle monsieur le Président de la
réponse conjoncturelle à
armer les émeutiers on a eu peu de tirs
contre les policiers les gendarmes je
veux cependant au constat des canines
policier a vu une balle de 9 mm dans son
gilet barbal qui aurait pu lui coûter sa
vie ce n'avait pas été bien équipé à
Lyon en tout cas dans dans les alentours
de Lyon et les tirs à la chevrotine
contre des policiers qui ont blessé
plusieurs policiers on a vu ici où là
des alertes de personnes qui auraient eu
des armes longues et sur son service
souvent pour détruire des bâtiments
publics ou des caméras de
vidéosurveillance parce que le travail
troisième métier était assez organisé
une fois qu'on s'attarde sur ce point
aussi sur le fait que il détruisait
d'abord des caméras de vidéos
surveillance par exemple avant
d'intervenir et donc nous n'avons pas vu
à ma connaissance de tir
d'armes dit type kalachnikov sur les
forces de l'ordre mais il est un risque
très important mais en revanche les
mortiers ont été particulièrement
utilisés chacun a pu le constater j'ai
donc non seulement demandé le lendemain
de ces émeutes de pouvoir faire que les
préfets sur tout le territoire national
empêche la construction la constitution
de cocktail Molotov et donc ne vendent
plus de l'essence en bidon dans les
stations essence la difficulté
évidemment c'est que l'essence est
parfois récupéré directement des
voitures et donc ça limite la portée
mais enfin c'était quand même déjà assez
et c'est efficace et interdise la vente
c'est pour ça que les fermetures
administratives de magasins dans vos
territoires le contrôle au douanes et
Jean merci ministère des grands publics
pour les venus à l'étranger je pense
notamment vers l'Allemagne la Belgique
qui permet d'acheter plus facilement des
mortiers mais également dans les tirs
dans les contrôles de pardon de relais
postaux et de colis puisque des
commandes sont faites illégalement sur
Internet ou de transport de mortiers
vous avez vu par exemple une affaire
puisque la préjudiciaire suit désormais
particulièrement c'est filières il n'y a
pas d'autres mots nous avons fait par
exemple 300 kg à porte de clients en
cours ce matin ou hier soir je ne sais
plus qui montre l'efficacité des
services de pêche judiciaires il est
évident qu'une partie des mortiers était
stockée pour la nuit du 13 au 14 juillet
et peut-être a été anticipé comme marbe
par destination je pense d'ailleurs à
des élus qui ont été le fait de s'étire
dans la maire de Pontoise qui était
brûlée du fait d'être sœur de mortier
par exemple chacun a pu le constater
voilà Monsieur monsieur le Président
quelques mots le fait déclenchant la
façon dont le ministère a géré les
choses mais la façon dont il compte les
gérer demain ou après-demain il est bien
difficile de savoir ce qui va se passer
dans les jours qui viennent nous
constatons cependant un calme revenu
partout sur le territoire national et
nous sommes toujours évidemment
extrêmement attentifs aux heures et aux
jours qui merci Monsieur le Ministre
plusieurs collègues ont demandé la
parole d'abord Madame Jacqueline stage
brignot Monsieur Jérôme Durin Madame
Brigitte l'airbier Monsieur François
bonhomme madame Marie-Pierre de la
Gontrie madame difolco monsieur
alamarque et
merci Monsieur Miss merci d'être venu en
nous aujourd'hui je sais que votre tâche
n'est pas facile les tâches des élus
dont je fais partie n'est pas facile non
plus
moi tout d'abord je voulais rendre
hommage à la police au gendarmes aux
pieds du Val-d'Oise qui depuis des nuits
ne dorment pas et font face à comme vous
l'avez dit des émeutiers et je pense que
chacun d'entre nous doit comprendre que
la plupart des Français soutiennent tous
ces effectifs de police de gendarmerie
et de pompiers parce que ce qu'il
constate aujourd'hui je peux vous dire
qu'il y a aujourd'hui des habitants qui
s'expriment de manière assez effrayante
parfois mais parce qu'ils sont exaspérés
les Français aujourd'hui c'est la
réalité donc on a beaucoup parlé depuis
quelques jours bon je remercie vous nous
avez donné des informations certaines on
les avait mais je vous remercie de les
avoir expliqué je reviendrai pas sur le
drame parce que tout le monde constate
que ce qui s'est passé tiendra mais
est-ce que ça justifiait ce que nous
avons vécu moi je crois pas moi je le
dis clairement ça ne justifie pas ce que
la France a connu ce drame ne le
justifie à aucun voilà ça c'est clair
alors on s'est beaucoup posé de
questions effectivement à juste titre
sur l'argent qu'on a dépensé depuis des
années pour certains quartiers et je
fais partie de ces élus qui s'est
beaucoup battu pour la petite de la
ville et je fais partie de ces élus
aujourd'hui qui se questionne beaucoup
pour du ticket de cet argent public
qu'on a beaucoup dépensé donc
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous poser des
questions parce que il y a des sujets
dont on ne veut pas parler monsieur le
ministre mais je souhaite qu'on en parle
moi je vis pas dans le sixième dans le
septième ou dans le 8e je suis dans le
95 donc voilà je voulais juste le
préciser et moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé
pour faire en sorte que tous les avants
quel que soit leur origine et leur
couleur de peau vivent sur le code de la
République parce que je pense que c'est
une chance pour tous les enfants de ce
pays quel qu'il soit sauf qu'aujourd'hui
force est de constater que oui vous
allez me dire
la plupart des gens qui sont arrêtés
sont français d'accord mais ça ne veut
plus rien dire aujourd'hui ils sont
comment en français et moi ça
m'interroge donc je voudrais savoir
quand même si un jour afin que nous
puissions y travailler nous allons
pouvoir connaître quels sont ses enfants
issus l'immigration
issues d'une immigration pour lequel
probablement des choses ont été ratées
puisqu'ils ne considère pas comme
français puisqu'ils ont une haine de la
France que moi élue malheureusement
depuis quelques années je n'ai jamais
ressenti comme je le ressens aujourd'hui
cette haine de la France certains gamins
dans les banlieues sont capables de dire
à des gens d'origine africaine
totalement intégrées tu es noir dehors
mais tu es blanc dedans c'est pas neutre
cette phrase ce n'est pas ne cette
phrase donc si on ne pose pas ça si on
ne dit pas ça et si on essaye pas de
comprendre qu'il y a quelque chose que
collectivement on a raté je pense que
nous n'y arriverons pas donc pourquoi ne
pas un jour avoir l'honnêteté nous dire
que la plupart des jeunes qui ont commis
des exactions depuis qu'à 5 jours sont
issus immigration c'est une réalité
c'est factuels et être dans l'ennemi
dans le déni ne nous permet pas
d'avancer voilà et moi je me pose une
question qui est responsable de cette
haine de la France alors que ce pays a
accueilli sans réserve parce que c'est
normal parce que c'est la générosité de
la France leurs parents leurs
grands-parents ça n'a posé de problème à
personne et que deux ou trois
générations après nous en sommes là donc
ne pas vouloir nous donner les chiffres
de ces mots issus l'immigration qui ont
pillé qui ont cassé ne nous permettra
pas d'avancer pour deux raisons c'est
que 16 ans mais non je voudrais juste
finir je voudrais juste finir ses
enfants là n'ont pas eu aussi au sein de
leur famille une transmission de leur
propre histoire parce qu'ils ont une
histoire ces enfants-là leurs parents
sont pas arrivés par hasard et c'est
aussi aux parents de transmettre
l'histoire familiale l'histoire
familiale elle se porte elle se et elle
se défend et si nous ne parlons pas de
cette réalité là Monsieur ministre nous
n'y arriverons pas merci madame monsieur
Durand oui pour être dans une réalité
qui n'est pas alternative parce que je
crois qu'il n'y a quand même qu'une
catégorie de Français les Français et
puis il y a ceux qui sont les 10% qui
ont été cités par le ministre qui ne
sont pas des Français mais on va pas
entrer quand même dans le détail
génétique des populations dont on parle
un peu choquant les propos de notre
collègue monsieur le ministre je vais
d'abord vous dire que nous sommes
satisfaits du dispositif de sécurité qui
a mis en oeuvre on sait que les
situations étaient difficiles pour les
forces de l'ordre et qu'il a fallu
beaucoup de de coordination d'efforts de
leur part toutes catégories confondues
pour que la situation qui était bien mal
engagée ça pèse et on espère que
l'apaisement du rage veut vous dire que
j'ai observé dans mon propre département
à Mâcon une excellente coordination sous
la houlette du préfet entre différentes
catégories de force de l'ordre les
gendarmes mobiles le GIGN le
commissariat local la BAC il faut rendre
hommage à tous ceux qui ont contribué à
au retour de l'apaisement trois
questions en rafale
la loop me et l'article
435-1 de du code de sécurité à
l'intérieur on a beaucoup débattu
pendant le pays du refus d'obtempérer
on était revenu sur la Loire de 2017
j'ai entendu le garder saut indiqué
qu'il était pas hostile à réexamen en la
matière et
notre proposition de
d'amendement et de modification du texte
et toujours sur la table je voulais
savoir si vous aviez des chiffres
comparés des refuses de tempérer pour ce
qui concerne d'un côté la police de
l'autre côté la gendarmerie qui pourrait
être nous éclairer sur la façon dont ça
se passe sur le territoire national en
la matière deuxième sujet c'est celui
des déclarations d'un bloc syndical
majoritaire dans la police qui nous ont
beaucoup choqué tout à l'heure on s'est
mis aux questions gouvernement du
syndicat de la magistration et de ses
propos j'aurais aimé aussi qu'on puisse
s'inquiéter de ce qui a été dit dans un
tract ou des syndicats policiers
voulaient s'en prendre aux nuisibles des
carrés en guerre voire en résistance
voilà je pense que c'est très inquiétant
et je voulais savoir quel est votre
réaction sur ce sujet et puis dans une
paysage politique où il n'est plus
d'extrême gauche je voulais savoir ce
que vous pensez des milices des
initiatives qui sont produites sur le
centre du territoire ou des
citoyens on sait qu'il y a eu quelques
militaires à Lorient ce sont organisés
spontanément pour venir en ordre aux
forces de l'ordre là aussi une forme
d'inquiétude nous habite merci merci
monsieur Durand Madame Brigitte
l'herbier
oui monsieur le ministre vous avez
évoqué un nombre important de mineurs
interpellé lors des émeutes le président
Macron a insisté sur la reprise en main
nécessaire de l'autorité parentale par
les parents sur ses enfants délinquants
je suis absolument d'accord avec ce
besoin d'encadrement familial et où tout
au moins un encadrement éducatif chargé
d'autorité sur l'enfant j'aimerais
monsieur le ministre que vous soyez
quand même en messager auprès de
monsieur le Président de la République
pour évoquer le besoin d'entendre aussi
les enfants en bas âge en souffrance
dans leur foyer
270 enfants sont sous ordonnés en
judiciaire de placement dans le Nord
depuis plusieurs mois
considérer en grand danger et
ses ordonnances ne sont pas suivies des
faits faute de place dans les foyers
largement occupé par les mineurs
étrangers isolés et par la difficulté à
recruter des nouvelles assistantes
familiales compétents professionnels
est éduqué dans une violence dès son
plus jeune âge comment trouver un
échappatoire rien excuse les dégâts
occasionner ces derniers jours rien rien
ne justifierait de ne pas appliquer des
peines exemplaires tant aux mineurs
violents qu'à leur famille indifférente
à l'avenir de leur progéniture les
selles abandon rien car ces actes sont
inqualifiables impensables honteux et
nous remercions les forces de l'ordre
d'avoir été en première ligne merci
aussi aux pompiers aux élus symboles
visés par ses attaques mais on va devoir
travailler ensemble pour sauver notre
République
le président buffet et les membres de la
commission des lois sont prêts à
réfléchir sereinement pour éviter la
reprise de ce genre d'attaque
je pense qu'en amont un travail de
reprise en main de la situation de
l'enfant sans danger est inévitable les
départements font de leur mieux mais
l'État doit les soutenir en priorité
dans leurs actions les enfants engagés
appellent depuis des mois voire des
années au secours le nombre de violences
familiales explosent les procureurs
généraux viennent ici régulièrement
l'évoquer au sein du Sénat
ne laissons pas les enfants évoluer dans
ces violences car ils ne reproduiront
peut-être si rien n'est fait monsieur le
ministre vous qui êtes proche des
concitoyens et je suis bien placé pour
le savoir à Tourcoing transmettez à
monsieur le Président qu'il est grand
temps de sauver les enfants en bas âge
ces situations que je viens d'évoquer
sont en parallèle de notre réflexion sur
la violence de ces derniers jours mais
tout est lié pour comprendre et
travailler sur l'avenir
il y a pas de question
je voudrais savoir que penser de pouce
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre comme beaucoup en regardant les
images de ces derniers jours je me suis
posé la question suivante comment un
fait divers tragique au demeurant a pu
mettre à feu et ascendre tant de vie
dans notre pays je crois que c'est la
première fois qu'on a vu un tel
déferlement de violence je suis comme la
majorité des Français a très grande
majorité j'ai un mélange de sidération
de stupeur de tristesse et de solidarité
totale à l'égard de nos forces de
sécurité policier gendarme et
sapeurs-pompiers les dégâts que nous
avons que cela occasionné sont
considérables et il va falloir payer et
remettre en état tous ces bâtiments
publics tous ces incendies tous ces
véhicules brûlés et indemniser tous les
commerçants qui ont été fortement
impactés
naturellement cela débouche sur beaucoup
de questions et d'interrogations qu'il
ne s'agira pas ce soir avec une simple
audition d'essayer de traiter je pense
que les semaines et les mois qui vont
arriver vont être l'occasion vraiment
d'aller sur le fond des choses
naturellement aussi je voudrais ajouter
que la colère ne serait en aucun cas
constitué un passeport pour la violence
de même que rien absolument rien ne
serait justifié excusez son usage
débridé vous avez donc monsieur le
ministre tout notre soutien sans
restriction face à la façon dont l'ordre
a été rétabli et si cela doit passer
dans les prochains mois par une analyse
de profonde et nécessaire des causes on
pourra évidemment évoquer tout un tas
d'institutions ça n'est pas le ministère
de l'Intérieur qui est en cause c'est la
question évidemment de l'école de notre
rapport en France à l'autorité à tout ce
qui est verticale à la contestation
Toutes les figure de l'autorité qu'elles
soient juge qu'elle soit professeur
qu'elle soit maire ou qu'elle soit force
et qui a diffusé un sentiment de
déresponsabilité générale et sur fond
aussi quand même je voudrais le dire ici
d'un discours de complaisance ici et là
qui consiste à faire porter la
responsabilité sur d'autres causes qui
ne sont pas majeures en espèces je parle
la cause du racisme la cause de
l'insuffisance de la politique de la
ville le mépris social ou la
discrimination dont l'agent l'État
serait la Jean tout cela relève de la
simple dénégation du réel et nous mène
tout droit à une forme
d'irresponsabilité je rappelle que Ian
France qui tranquille et qui est
silencieuse qui elle a été également
sidérée par cette exposition de violence
et qu'elle attend d'abord un retour à la
paix à l'ordre et à la sécurité première
des libertés je voudrais maintenant vous
parler deux points et deux facteurs
particuliers qui me semblent avoir été
assez nouveau dans ces dans cette
explosion de violence d'abord le jeune
âge des émeutiers vous l'avez dit un
grand nombre de personnes interpellées
au moins de 16 ans ou moins de 17 ans
c'est une jeunesse ça a été indiqué par
le monde qui est devenu hyper connecté
mais dans le même temps complètement des
culturé complètement
déstructuré socialement et dépourvu de
toute retenue et totalement désignée je
crois que là ça marque vraiment et ça
donne la mesure du renoncement dans cet
homme de de nos institutions qui ont été
complètement affaiblis et affaissés je
pense naturellement à l'école et puis
deuxième une question particulière sur
l'usage détourné qui a été fait par les
mortiers d'artifice nous avons vu des
images tout à fait spectaculaires ou les
les émeutiers sont procurés moult et
force mortier d'artifice par tout moyen
comment se fait-il qu'aujourd'hui on se
procure en France aussi facilement on
achète aussi facilement sur Internet
notamment des mortiers d'artifices qui
servent uniquement à cibler nos forces
de l'ordre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez depuis le début de
ces de ces difficultés et après la mort
du jeune Naël vous avez tenu des propos
que pour notre part nous avons trouvé
responsable
tentant évidemment au fil des événements
de faire en sorte que la paix civile
puisse revenir et on sait que dans ce
type de circonstances le pari n'est pas
gagné d'avance et nous l'avons vu vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure de manière
très responsable également
ce n'était pas exactement la formule
misante était pas loin bien malin celui
qui pense avoir la solution n'avait pas
utilisé exactement ces termes mais
c'était l'idée bienheureux voilà donc
effectivement gardons-nous de tout
Simplice mais de toute solution magique
il se pose cependant me semble-t-il
d'ores et déjà deux types de questions
auxquelles il nous faut répondre quand
je dis nous c'est parce que nous
considérons parlementaire que nous
sommes aussi acteurs de tout cela
la première c'est une question
d'ailleurs que mon collègue Jérôme
durain vous a posé sans doute en raison
du temps de réponse limité vous n'avez
pas pu y répondre complètement c'est
comment
réconcilier la police et la population
puisque sans être trop longue nous
voyons bien qu'il y a une difficulté de
ce point de vue là
et évidemment
comment faire face à ce qui peut être
perçu comme
une discrimination comme des pratiques
discriminatoires qui sont documentées et
comment faire face à ces situations sans
les nier sans les caricaturer nous les
caricaturons pas mais sans les nier et
je crains que certains ne les ne les ni
la deuxième chose c'est
les modalités de d'intervention des
forces de l'ordre est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas que il est nécessaire sans
doute de recadrer ou de préciser les
modalités d'usage des armes par les
forces de l'ordre sans doute que trois
séances de tir par an et largement
insuffisant pour que les personnels
soient en situation de réaction
suffisamment adaptée et donc au fond
toute la question de la formation des
policiers et sans doute en cause j'y
ajoute
sans doute la question de la
rémunération et au fond de la
considération que nous devons leur
apporter et on peut retrouver le serpent
de mer des millions d'heures
supplémentaires qui ne sont pas payées
et donc nous avons affaire évidemment
des forces de l'ordre exténuées et qui
ont évidemment beaucoup plus de
difficultés à accomplir leurs missions
sereinement voilà les deux questions que
je souhaitais poser de la ganterie
Madame Catherine difolco
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre moi je suis inquiète parce
que j'ai entendu je crois que c'est
samedi soir un reportage radiophonique
c'est un journaliste qui était place
Bellecour à Lyon et qui interviewait des
jeunes voilà et qui est ce jeune disait
on va pas y aller ce soir parce que ils
sont trop nombreux effectivement il y
avait beaucoup de force de police il y
avait le raid la Brice en doute je sais
plus exactement si je ne dis on va rien
faire ce soir ils sont trop nombreux on
revient mais t'inquiète pas ne
t'inquiète pas on va revenir quand ce
sera le moment on reviendra donc bah moi
j'allais dire je suis inquiète parce que
vous n'avez pas pouvoir disposer des
dispositifs que vous avez mis en place
que la préfecture a mis en place à
l'utaméternam donc dès que les
dispositifs seront allégés ça risque de
refamber de nouveau donc que pensez-vous
faire pour éviter merci
merci
[Musique]
merci Président je souhaite d'abord bien
évidemment comme d'autres collègues
rendre hommage ici aux forces de l'ordre
sapeurs-pompiers et dire à Monsieur le
Ministre que bien évidemment nous le
soutenons les uns et les autres ici
surtout ces bandes dans les actions
qu'il peut qu'il peut avoir pour
protéger les biens et les personnes sur
notre territoire nous sommes ici au
Sénat les représentants institutionnels
et constitutionnels des communes on sait
le rôle essentiel qui représente les
mers au niveau certes des équipements
publics pour le mieux vivre de nos
populations mais aussi dans les nombreux
litiges qu'il parviennent à résoudre
faisant ainsi œuvre de justice de paix
c'est le qui a disparu dans les dans les
années 50 je crois savoir que vous avez
donné des consignes aux forces de
l'ordre afin que les élus soient
protégés eux qui sont aujourd'hui pris
pour cible par ceux qui ne supportent
pas notre démocratie
pouvez-vous nous dire quelle forme
prendra désormais cette coopération
d'autre part comptez-vous travailler
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale cela rejoint des questions qui
ont été prélables préalablement posées
afin que nous institutions soit aussi à
nouveau apprise dans les programmes
scolaires et que leur portée symbolique
est nécessaire au fonctionnement de
notre société soit assimilée
merci Monsieur Marc président canner
merci Monsieur président monsieur le
ministre
premier mot pour n'ont pas répondre à
Madame stage Brignoud mais quand même
pour rappeler cette phrase qui ira
sûrement des choses à certaines
personnes je la cite nous pensons que
l'immigration fait partie de la France
et des Français depuis toujours
l'immigration est un fait qui fait aussi
la France qui a fait son passé et qui
fera sans doute son avenir il ne sert à
rien d'être contre que veut dire être
contre le mouvement des hommes sur la
Terre Gérald Darmanin décembre 2022
Assemblée nationale monsieur le ministre
j'aurais pu signer votre déclaration je
le dis très simplement et je pense que
il ne faut pas avoir notamment entre
sénateurs madame chers collègues des
propos caricaturaux qui ne font que
mettre de l'huile sur le feu je le dis
et je ferme la parenthèse en la matière
et je vous invite à lire le l'excent
ouvrage de Monsieur héron François
errant professeur au Collège de France
sur l'immigration le pandémie je reviens
à notre sujet
initial monsieur le ministre
nous chercherons à comprendre les causes
et analyser et porter des propositions
d'ailleurs dans ce cadre au nom de mon
groupe j'ai demandé l'organisation d'un
débat parlementaire dans le cadre de
l'article 50-1 de la Constitution
j'espère que Madame borne pourra
répondre à cette sollustation qui relève
de sa seule autorité
néanmoins nous avons une rencontre de
travail avec le Premier ministre il est
à 48 heures à Matignon avec l'ensemble
des prisons de groupe et j'ai pu
rappeler au nom de mon groupe ici
représenté par Madame de la ganterie et
Monsieur du Rhin
je retourne pour savoir non a priori
j'ai interpellé combien de le faire
d'ailleurs notre collègue du Rhin sur la
formation des policiers sur
l'interprétation et l'évaluation de
l'article 435-1 du code de la sécurité
intérieure mais j'ai une question
complémentaire sur un sujet bien précis
mais qui prend toute sa place et son
importance dans le débat de ce jour à
savoir le développement de la
généralisation des caméras piétons
et
je ne vous cache pas ma surprise à la
réponse qui m'a été faite par la
première ministre me disant oui les
caméras piétons sont totalement
généralisées opérationnels moi j'y suis
très favorable depuis la loi égalité
citoyenneté de 2017 que nous avons porté
sur cette partie là avec Bernard
Cazeneuve et j'ai donc interrogé après
le ministre sur le fait est-ce que les
deux motards incriminés à Nanterre
portait les caméras piétons il
n'emportait pas et par définition elles
n'ont pas été enclenchées puisque n'en
partait pas je considère nous
considérons que les caméras piétons ne
sont pas l'alpha Omega des solutions
mais permettent de sûrement d'apaiser
une relation entre incontrôlée et des
personnes qui apportent ce qui apportent
ce contrôle et la réponse d'après
ministre m'a un peu étonné mais je veux
pas vous mettre en difficulté monsieur
le ministre mais me disant mais quand on
est motard on ne porte pas de caméra
piéton je ne vois pas ce qui
techniquement laisse à penser que pour
des motards il y aura un empêche ment
technique apporter les caméras piéton et
je pense que l'enquête du Lucien ne peut
pas se baser uniquement sur de la vidéo
surveillance ou sur des visios faites
par des citoyens qui étaient présents à
ce moment-là s'il n'y avait pas eu de
vidéosurveillance et s'il n'avait pas
été présent ces citoyens filmant la
scène qu'est-ce qu'on aurait pu
interpréter du du sujet donc je serais
heureux de vous entendre en la matière
merci même la présentation
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues bon je
vais me répéter d'autres l'ont dit avant
moi et c'est bien que nous le
partageions rien ne justifie
effectivement les violences mais quand
même rien ne justifie aussi la mort d'un
enfant de 17 ans il faut que les choses
soient quand même claires de ce point de
ce point de vue là alors moi aussi
j'étais à la réunion convoquée par
madame la Première ministre mardi
dernier et je lui ai dit que nous avions
déjà traversé de phases la première
c'est la phase de l'émotion
et la seconde c'est ce sont les
violences
inadmissibles que je condamne très
fortement et je ne reviens pas sur tout
ce qui a été saccagé dans notre pays et
les attaques scandaleuses contre des
élus et donc si la situation est moins
tendue aujourd'hui je crois que nous
devons être clairvoyants nous ne sommes
pas à l'abri d'une possible troisième
phase donc dans ces conditions je pense
qu'il faut rapidement apporter des
réponses à court à moyen et à long terme
pour rester sur le champ de la sécurité
parce que j'aurais pu venir aussi sur
d'autres champs mais sur celui de la
sécurité et du maintien de l'ordre je
sais que l'équation entre la prévention
l'accompagnement et la protection que
doivent porter la police c'est cette
équation c'est un véritable défi
à relever par les policiers eux-mêmes au
quotidien c'est un métier difficile
d'être policier et je trouve que c'est
la situation est d'autant plus
inquiétante que
la classe enfin certaines personnes de
la classe politique
en rajoute fond de la surenchère des
amalgames douteux des propos qui bien
évidemment encore une fois font le lien
entre sécurité et immigration avec tout
le respect que j'ai pour vous Madame est
stage brignot et je ne reviendrai pas
sur les propos de Monsieur Kanner mais
vous voyez dans une cour d'école ou à la
sortie de l'école quand un gamin de 8
ans qui a le teint un peu bronzé
on pense que c'est un immigré alors que
c'est son arrière-grand-père qui est
arrivé en France c'est pas son
grand-père c'est pas son papa c'est son
arrière-grand-père ce môme et français
je suis française je suis française et
je suis Alexis c'est la question c'est
ce que vous avez évoqué madame
hustachepriot et je dis attention
attention
vous mettez de l'huile sur le feu avec
vos propos
bah oui c'est sérieux bien évidemment
que c'est sérieux
donc et puis je crois qu'en Tom et femme
politique et surtout en tant que
parlementaire on ne peut pas s'exonérer
d'un certain nombre de choses certes le
gouvernement propose des lois mais ces
lois ce sont les parlementaires qui les
votent donc nous sommes responsables
aussi de la situation nous avons des
responsabilités et il serait quand même
assez inquiétant de s'exonérer de ces
responsabilités nous votons la loi et
donc les missions qui sont confiées aux
policiers c'est nous qui lui avons qui
leur avons conféré ces missions et donc
monsieur le ministre moi vous savez j'ai
plusieurs dadas concernant les policiers
celui de la formation bien évidemment
des policiers je pense qu'il faut la
renforcer tout en tant que la durée de
formation et puis celui du retour à une
police de proximité je suis désolé
depuis qu'il n'existe plus de police de
proximité partout dans notre pays les
liens se sont déliter entre
je n'ai pas dit que c'était la faute à
Sarkozy madame madame Stach Briot vous
savez j'ai loué très fine mais c'est un
constat depuis qu'il n'y a plus de
police de proximité dans notre pays les
liens se sont délités entre les forces
de police et la jeunesse et moi
j'aimerais bien que Monsieur le Ministre
répondent est-ce qu'il a l'intention de
revenir à cette fonction de nos
policiers merci Madame la présente
Madame la présente Gatel merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre merci
très sincère pour votre total engagement
et votre transparence et merci aussi à
toutes les forces de l'ordre qui sont si
sollicités si éprouvées et parfois même
accablé mes collègues ont chacun
évoquer un angle des choses et ceci
montre bien que nous devons être
aujourd'hui dans une approche systémique
parce que je crois que les causes et les
réponses sont multi FLAC factorielle et
qu'au-delà de la crise que nous
traversons je pense que le mal est
profond et que la révolte sous toutes
ses formes y compris dans nos campagnes
parce qu'aujourd'hui on parle des
révoltes
urbaines il y a quelques temps parlaient
de la révolte des ruraux tout cela
couvent et chacun de nous en tant des
personnes extrêmement modérées
aujourd'hui dire que demain elle
voteront différemment et que il n'y a
plus aucun tabou sur certains sujets et
que il y a une attente très forte de
retour alors de retour au vivre ensemble
et l'ordre vous l'avez dit vous-même et
la sécurité sur la meilleure protection
des plus faibles en tout cas si on
s'intéresse à la situation et au
comportement des plus jeunes en Afrique
je crois que l'on dit il faut tout un
village pour éduquer un enfant et je
pense que c'est très vrai je pense
monsieur ministre vous n'êtes en vous
êtes en charge des questions de sécurité
mais on ne peut pas ne pas parler
tout le reste notamment en matière de
prévention la famille et le premier lieu
d'éducation il viendra l'idée de
personnes de rejeter le principe de
responsabilité individuelle et moi je
suis très sensible à l'interpellation de
notre collègue qui parle de la nécessité
parfois de protéger les enfants et de
les mettre à l'abri et leur donner une
chance de s'émanciper et de s'éduquer
parfois hélas en quittant leur famille
pour aller dans des lieux qui sont des
lieux d'éducation qui doivent être
positifs la deuxième chose Monsieur le
Ministre c'est que je rejoins un peu la
présidente assassine dans les zones de
gendarmerie nous voyons que les
gendarmes vivent au milieu de la
population moi j'ai été maire j'ai vu le
chef de gendarmerie jouait au foot avec
d'autres ses enfants aller à la même
école moi je ne souhaite pas transformer
le policier en coach sportif mais il
n'empêche que quand vous rencontrez les
au quotidien dans votre vie vous les
regardez de manière différente et vous
n'êtes plus face à face dans des moments
de tension et de violence et moi je
crois à une présence à plonçal la police
de proximité sans connotation d'époque
voilà mais je crois qu'il y a sans doute
de la prévention qui donnerait un rôle
sans doute différent à la police mais
nous préserverait enfin Monsieur le
Ministre dernière clicha alors il
s'adresse pas à vous mais encore une
fois moi je pense que vous êtes au
centre de tout et qu'il y a une vraie
question sur la mixité oui au centre moi
je suis très contente qu'on dit ça bien
heureux celui qui est au centre monsieur
le minier bref je reviens madame de la
ganterie à mon propos je pense qu'on a
un vrai je pense qu'on a un vrai sujet
sur les conditions de vie et
l'assignation à résidence de certaines
personnes à la campagne comme à la ville
et je pense que si nous confions aux
élus locaux la gestion notamment du
logement social je pense qu'elle serait
plus heureuse parce qu'il y aurait une
mixité sociale qui serait pratiqué en
matière de dentelle et je pense que sans
doute qu'il y aurait moins de tension et
moins de ghetto qu'en pensez-vous
monsieur ça devait se terminer par une
question je vous remercie merci dernière
intervention madame Dominique verrière
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi je voudrais tout d'abord
saluer en fait les habitants de de ces
quartiers politiques de la ville qui
pour beaucoup se sont engagés pour
sauver des bâtiments et ne pas forcément
laisser faire essayer d'empêcher toutes
ces détériorations car ils n'ont pas
oublié qu'ils en étaient les premières
victimes et nous ne devons pas l'oublier
non plus donc je voulais le saluer
derrière ces émeutes il semblerait qu'il
y ait quand même une organisation
facilité par des messageries ou les
réseaux sociaux souhaitent mais une
organisation et d'ailleurs le fait que
vous ayez tout d'abord arrêter des
jeunes et que plus vous avancez dans vos
investigations et plus vous arrêtez des
plus vieux montre là encore qu'il doit
bien y avoir une organisation alors
quelle est ce type d'organisation est-ce
que ce serait lié au trafic de drogue
comme on le dit souvent qui profite de
ce chaos par ailleurs on voit vous
l'avez dit vous-même que vous avez les
forces de sécurité intérieure on saisit
encore 300 kg de mortier si j'ai bien
compris
sont-ils en train de se réarmer doit-on
effectivement le craindre
et ça je me fais donc l'écho de ce que
vient de dire notre collègue Catherine
difolco et donc que faire pour anéantir
le pouvoir de cela et enfin j'arrive au
maire célibataire alors je crois
vraiment à l'autorité parentale et je
crois pas que une mère soit forcément
plus faible qu'un homme mais malgré tout
le maire de l'ail des roses elle a dit
lui-même
certaines mères n'y arrivent plus voir
sont elles-mêmes victimes de leurs
enfants qui souvent sont tombés sous
l'influence de ces fameuses
organisateurs dont je parlais un peu
plus avant alors moi je vais vous parler
des pairs où sont-ils les pairs et
permettez-moi de pousser un coup de
gueule quand je vois le père de Noël qui
se porte partie civile
il ne faut quand même pas avoir beaucoup
de fierté pour ne pas avoir été là pour
élever son enfant mais essayez de
profiter de sa mort
merci Madame Berrien
il nous appartient maintenant de
répondre
un peu plus de 5 minutes quand même
merci c'est gentil merci monsieur le
Président
peut-être deux mots de mots généraux et
puis répondre à chacune de vos questions
il a été fait référence dans les médias
et même ici ou là par vous interventions
aux émeutes dites de 2005
je voudrais comparer des choses et
évidemment dire qu'il y a des choses
très différentes en 2005 il y a 21 jours
d'émeutes et au bout du dixième jour le
gouvernement de la République sur
demande du Président de la République si
je me rappelle dans l'histoire politique
impose à son ministre de l'Intérieur de
l'époque l'état d'urgence
on voit que d'ailleurs ça a duré malgré
l'état d'urgence puis c'est le plus de
jours d'émeutes après qu'avant et chacun
se rappelle sans doute que c'est une
vague de froid extrêmement forte qui a
calmé une partie des ardeurs des
délinquants ou des émotiers de l'époque
ils étaient plus âgés beaucoup plus âgés
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai demandé qu'on me
sorte les comparaisons je ne les ai pas
encore mais à coup sûr ils étaient plus
âgés
moins de ville était concernée
chacun se rappelle d'ailleurs que
Marseille à l'époque n'avait pas connu
des meute parce qu'on expliquait que le
trafic de drogue calmé les ardeurs
de ceux qui voulaient être ébutier il
n'y avait pas de réseaux sociaux il me
semble que LCI devait être la seule la
chaîne de formation continue mais je
n'ai plus de bons souvenirs en tout cas
c'était pas tout à fait demande
médiatique et même de mimétique
et il y avait malgré tout il y avait eu
malgré tout à l'époque d'abord de la
part me semble-t-il des décideurs
politiques à défaut de jugement sur ce
qui était arrivé dans l'affaire initiale
et par ailleurs qui a sans doute
contribué
à l'excitation elle a des vacances et
par ailleurs à la fin je constate qu'il
y avait aussi des revendications
sociales d'où les plans et notamment
chacun s'en souvient des femmes plans
Borlo et autres qui ont répondu à ces
difficultés là nous avons des choses
très différentes quatre jours d'émeutes
nous avons
jusqu'à présent à utiliser l'état
d'urgence d'ailleurs je constate que si
personne ne reprochent il est parfois ça
nous approchait médiatiquement mais nous
revoche d'avoir pris d'urgence je suis
pas sûr qu'il nous aurait beaucoup aidé
et d'ailleurs je n'ai pas proposé au
Président de la République à la première
ministre puisque l'état d'urgence
avaient comme grand avantage comme dans
un état d'urgence terroriste de faire
des perquisitions administratives l'idée
de donner aux utilisateurs les pouvoirs
qu'on de la République où les juges
comme là il n'y avait pas d'organisation
criminelle comme telles que nous l'avons
vu il y a d'autres organisations j'y
reviendrai même à ma Satis et
perquisitions administratives sauf et on
va pas à l'instant où nous en parlions
n'était pas d'une utilité d'une grande
efficacité et j'ai fait le pari que la
démonstration de force et
d'interpellation était de nature à
calmer une partie des émeutiers dont je
veux dire ici que d'après les services
de Missan intérieur mais ce sont des
chiffres qui forcément ne sont pas
scientifiques ils étaient entre 8000 et
peut-être un peu plus peut-être un peu
moins les groupes très mobiles souvent
cagoulés mais on peut pas considérer
qu'il y avait des centaines de milliers
de personnes dans ces quartiers ou des
millions de personnes vivent qui se sont
rebeller contre la République donc je
pense que même si les images sont
extrêmement choquantes même si les
agitations et les dégradations sont
extrêmement fortes même s'il y a 800
policiers gendarmes blessés fort
heureusement aucun n'a le pronostic
vital engagé je veux aussi dire qu'il
s'agit de tout au plus de quelques
milliers de personnes qui ont commis ces
difficultés ce qui est à la fois un
problème très important et en même temps
nous ne permet pas de mettre dans le
même sac tous les habitants des
quartiers populaires
le deuxième sujet que je voudrais
évoquer avec vous c'est celui de la
police
d'ailleurs je profiterai peut-être pour
répondre à Madame de la Contrie j'en
excuse auprès du sénateur du rein et qui
connaît le respect que m'inspire
centrale si je n'ai pas été très complet
pendant la question au gouvernement
évidemment
la police nationale et avec la
gendarmerie je trouve que le débat peut
gendarmerie
je l'entends monter mais il est pas très
correct d'abord parce que il y a 25% des
vacances aux autres gendarmerie 75% zone
police chacun s'accordera à dire que
c'est pas le même type de délinquance
deuxièmement il y a encore quelques
années vous discutiez avec le minisateur
de l'époque de la Réforme de la
gendarmerie nationale puisque dans
l'affaire des Traoré à Persan c'était
exactement les mêmes discussions autour
d'un supposé racisme de se poser mauvais
interpellation
il y a du bon dans la gendarmerie
nationale il y a du monde dans la police
nationale je crois qu'ils ne font pas
totalement le même métier je veux
constater avec vous cependant que 80%
d'intervention des gendarmes mobiles
sont en zone police et d'ailleurs quand
on dit il y a un rapport police
population je pense que si on avait un
on peut toujours discuter d'ailleurs
j'aime pas trop ce mot parce que pour
moi la police à gendarmerie sont dans la
population ils sont pas à part ils ont
des enfants qui vont à l'école ils ont
des habitations qu'ils ont des des maris
des femmes des parents ils changent de
métier ils sont issus de la population
c'est pas une population à part il
rentre pas dans le caserne dans le
commissariat sans jamais rencontrer leur
boulanger ou leurs voisins bon donc je
trouve que les distinguer les
populations est insultant pour eux mais
je comprends ce qu'on veut dire par ce
mot je ne veux pas le rejeter par
principe je crois que il n'y a pas dans
le statut militaire de la gendarmerie
nationale dans sa formation des choses
qui expliquerait que ça irait mieux que
des gendarmes avec des policiers
puisqu'on peut trouver bien des exemples
qui montrent que dans les villes
qui se sont agrandis et qui sont en zone
gendarmerie c'est le cas dans je prends
l'exemple de Libourne par exemple en
Gironde ou c'est le cas de Persan ils
connaissent ces mêmes difficultés on
peut sans doute inspirer ici ou là des
pratiques des uns et des autres mais je
ne suis pas sûr qu'il martingale quelque
part et en disant ça j'ai le plus grand
respect bien sûr pour le travail des
gendarmes pour le travail des policiers
le but du ministère intérieur c'est de
prendre le meilleur des deux forces et
pas de moins bon des deux forces parce
que si le moins bon de chaque côté c'est
pour ça qu'il faut faire très attention
en le rapprochement on aura l'occasion
sans doute de parler de la philosophie
du cristal
je veux dire que la police
si on veut bien
mettre ça à son crédit elle est le
réceptacle de tout ce qui n'a pas allé
de tout ce qui n'a pas aller jusqu'à
présent dans la société pour moi je vais
prendre un exemple qui voudra parler à
ceux qui sont attentifs aux questions
médicales ce sont les urgentistes de la
société si quelqu'un fume toute la
journée bois toute la journée
est stressé et en surcharge pondérale et
vit dans des conditions de non respect
de son corps il faut pas s'étonner qu'il
fasse une crise cardiaque ou un AVC
qu'est-ce qu'on fera on appellera les
pompiers ou le SAMU ils interviendront
le plus rapidement possible espérons-le
avec la formation la plus efficace
possible espérons-le avec les
technologies les plus modernes possibles
espérons-le et ils seront pas la vie de
cette personne
si cette personne meurt nous serions
bien
comment dirais-je sera bien méchant de
considérer que c'est dur gentil ce qui a
pas de sauver et qu'il faudrait
davantage encore le sélectionner
davantage encore exiger les choses de
lui sans doute qui peut encore
s'améliorer être plus rapide avant de
meilleur moyen être plus attentif à la
médecine enfin c'est pas lui
personnellement qui est responsable de
cette mort ici cette personne ne meurt
pas et qu'il l'a sauvé c'est pas lui qui
va lui faire changer d'attitude de ne
plus boire de ne plus manger de maigrir
c'est son médecin généraliste c'est
s'habitudes alimentaires c'est peut-être
même ses parents c'est peut-être même
son mode de vie donc je pense que la
police cristallise quand je dis la
police ce sont les forces de l'ordre
cristallise évidemment des faits
médiatiques et extrêmement complexe ce
ministère de l'Intérieur est un
ministère où tous les jours il se passe
de très nombreuses horreurs que fort
heureusement toute opinion ne connaît
pas parce que je crois qu'elle serait
alors aussi déprimée que les membres de
mon cabinet bien évidemment mais c'est
l'arrivée et après la police chacun le
sait la justice l'arrivée de toutes la
difficulté que la société a pas su
régler avant donc moi je veux bien tout
ce qu'on veut et les policiers parfois
connaissent des difficultés fortes y
compris dans leur vie personnelle
parfois de management qui sont
extrêmement toxiques mais je pense que
avant de poser ce genre de questions
pour se dire qu'ils ont une charge et
une surcharge physique et psychologique
très grande quand l'éducation va mieux
quand l'intégration a réussi quand le
logement est efficace parce qu'on sait
tous qu'il y a des liens entre tout ça
et d'autres encore alors je crois que il
y aurait moins de travail pour nos
policiers alors cependant pour répondre
à la question de la Gontrie très très
concrètement même la Contrie merci de
des propos que vous avez tenus et merci
d'ailleurs au groupe socialiste au sens
large et à tous ceux qui sont ici
d'avoir tenu ses propos
c'est un policier qui a été mis en
examen c'est pas tous les policiers qui
ont été mis en examen
alors est-ce qu'un policier peut
commettre des erreurs oui bien sûr
est-ce qu'il y a à améliorer la
formation sans aucun doute d'ailleurs
nous avons posé quatre fois plus la
formation
faut-il faire davantage sans doute sans
doute faut-il mieux sélectionner les
policiers très certainement je constate
avec vous si vous me le permettez que je
suis à la tête d'un ministère ou à part
les commissaires de police
ce que nous recrutons c'est souvent des
enfants pour apprendre notre mot de 18
de 19 de 20 ans qui n'ont pas fait de
très grandes études et qui choisissent
ce service de la nation par la police
gendarmerie je ne suis pas la tête lui
Sada justice où les gens peuvent des
concours avec +4 bac + 5 ou éducation
nationale aux gens sont très mal payés
par ailleurs comme les policiers mais
enfin ils ont un capital social très
important
mettons-nous quelques instants à la
place d'un majorité majorité de jeunes
qui choisissent ce service de la police
et de gendarmerie que nous devons former
nous
ok oui ça demande une exigence
supplémentaire parce qu'en plus ces
personnes ont la contrainte légitime des
armes et donc par ailleurs une
responsabilité supplémentaire et à nous
savoir pourquoi et pour quelle raison
ils veulent rentrer dans la police la
gendarmerie c'est la première question
que je pose à des policiers à des
gendarmes quand je les croise dans
l'école
on est tous toujours très touchés de nos
témoignages et il y a parfois des
questions qu'on peut se poser donc 1 je
veux dire que oui on doit améliorer sans
cesse et ce sera un travail jamais
terminé le travail des policiers et des
gendarmes sans aucun doute je suis le
premier à ne pas accepter à son instant
qu'on tutoie les personnes
c'est inacceptable qu'on est 15 ans
qu'on soit étranger en situation
irrégulière ou qu'on soit président
directeur général d'une société on ne
peut pas tutoyer les personnes alors
évidemment c'est plus facile à dire dans
les fauteuils du Sénat sur le terrain
mais c'est la hauteur de la Prestation
nationale nous ne sommes pas une bande
rivale contre une autre grande rivale
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça monsieur Durand
et vous le savez que j'ai pris à sa
tombe de décision lorsque j'ai vu des
policiers manifester en cagoule on n'est
pas une bande rivale contre une autre
bande rivale c'est pas ça la République
donc oui il faut sans cesse améliorer un
travail difficile de formation des
policiers oui vous avez raison Madame la
Gontrie trois tyran administratifs c'est
pas assez notamment les tirs dit en
mouvement parce que c'est ça la
difficulté quand je suis arrivé au
ministère de l'Intérieur la gaubrerie
60% des policiers seulement vers leurs
trois tirs administratifs c'est leur
administration qui est responsable de
leur sécurité et la première chose que
fait l'igpet de l'iggène c'est de
vérifier que le policier a fait trois
tirs administratifs et s'il n'a pas fait
il le sanctionne mais c'est pas lui qui
refuse de faire toiture administratif
c'est qu'il y a pas assez de stands de
tir c'est qu'il y a pas assez de temps
pour la formation c'est nous les
employeurs de ces policiers qui savent
responsables vous avez raison il faut
largement améliorer ça je crois que la
loi que vous avez votée nous permet de
le faire
vous avez raison aussi également il faut
sans doute que nous nous posions des
questions de compréhension du monde dans
lequel vivent les policiers des
gendarmes peut-être que le policier et
le gendarme et c'est le cas de toute
personne qui travaille finalement dans
sa filière professionnelle de se pose
pas assez de questions parce que par
manque de temps par manque de formation
par manque d'action de son
administration par management aussi la
question dans quel monde il évolue mais
cependant madame de La Gontrie
accordez-moi quand même
qu'on ne peut pas tout à fait dire qu'il
faut changer les lois j'entends la
question de la loi de février 2017
que le gouvernement de Monsieur
Cazeneuve a proposé dans d'autres
circonstances très certainement c'est
pas parce qu'à policier ne respecte pas
la loi qu'il faut changer forcément
cette loi d'ailleurs je constate que
beaucoup veulent que désormais je dis
giver sous le coup de l'émotion non non
j'ai beaucoup
j'ai dit beaucoup
ce monsieur ce policier qui a encore une
fois a droit à la présomption
d'innocence et je ne suis pas procureur
de la réplique je ne suis pas juge
n'a manifestement de mon point de vue et
je ne suis pas spécialiste au sens
formateur de la question mais je me
posais évidemment poser des questions
avant d'apporter une réponse publique
mais seulement pas respecté la loi 2017
parce que quelqu'un ne respecte pas une
loi il faudrait la changer c'est absurde
si quelqu'un fait du 184 km/h sur
l'autoroute BC la vitesse excessive de
130 à 120 ne résoudra rien puisque par
définition il ne respecte pas cette
vitesse je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas
réfléchir aux conditions d'emploi des
forces je dis que ça me paraît une
réponse trop rapide et trop facile
premièrement deuxièmement je veux dire
ici que
l'intervention de la police nationale
gendarmerie c'est la conséquence de 10
ans de difficultés entre pays qui ont
commencé avec des attentats
les attentats terroristes
un certain nombre de violences
inexcusables qui relève très souvent des
violences urbaines qui a très souvent
des forcené parce que le premier travail
des policiers gendarmes c'est souvent
intervenir sur des forçonnées où ils
ouvrent le feu des reflets d'obtempérer
alors j'ai bien compris les questions
qui m'ont été posées je vais vous donner
les réponses j'espère le plus précise
possible sur les refus de tempérer en
2022 il y en a eu 25800 fait connu par
les services de police et de gendarmerie
c'est à dire en moyenne un refus
d'obtempérer tous les 20 minutes
5329 dans des circonstances exposant
directement autrui le risque d'abord
de 2016 à 2022 il y a eu une hausse de
5,8% pour les refus et 27,3%
d'augmentation pour l'effet de refus de
tempéré dans les circonstances exposant
directement quelqu'un à la mort
et si je prends le travail qui est fait
par les policiers donc parce que je vous
ai donné les chiffres offerts simples et
c'est ce qu'on a constaté c'est pas ceux
qui existent au sens où les policiers
rames sont pas là qui amènent un
policier demandant de s'arrêter en ayant
constaté l'infraction on constate qu'ils
ont augmenté 220 6% et de même que le
nombre de récidives par le même
conducteur d'un véhicule augmenté de
155%
dans ces conditions est-ce que les
policiers légendaires notamment la loi
depuis 2017 augmentent leur intervention
pour tirer la réponse est non là encore
je veux dire que dans le débat qu'on a
eu c'est faux c'est pas parce qu'un
policier n'aurait pas respecté 2017 que
il y a une augmentation comme je l'ai lu
par 5 des tirs en zone police comme en
zone gendarmerie
en 2013 c'est le dernier enfin le
chiffre plutôt que j'ai
226 déclarations de tir opérationnelle
et accidentelle de manière générale
usage sur véhicule en mouvement 133
en 2016 donc au moment où j'imagine le
gouvernement de ce Cazeneuve a été
inspiré pour prendre sa législation 255
tirs administratifs 313
usages de larmes volontaires
opérationnelles en position gendarmerie
181 sur véhicule en mouvement
en 2017 l'année de la loi 394 tirs
opérationnels 313 pardon 429 pardon
usage de l'inventaire opérationnelle et
sur les Vikings mouvements 255 prenons
l'exemple alors 2020 c'est une année
covid me paraît pas une bonne
comparaison mais 2021 qui était une
année covid à moitié 290 tirs
opérationnels 341
usages volonté opérationnels 201 sur les
clients mouvements 2022 qui est une
année pleine sans covid 285 déclarations
de tirs opérationnels 317 usages d'armes
opérationnels 168 véhicules à mouvement
c'est-à-dire que la police à gendarmerie
c'est le contraire de ce qu'on raconte
il y a de plus en plus de tempérés et
j'utilise de moins en moins leurs armes
ça c'est la vérité des chiffres et j'ai
le détail police et gendarmerie si vous
le souhaitez monsieur le sénateur je
voulais passerai c'est exactement la
même chose dans les deux façons il y en
a pas une qui augmente et une qui baisse
c'est de baisse
donc je crois que on peut se poser des
questions encore une fois mise à
l'intérieur devant
l'incroyable force qu'on les force de
l'ordre par définition et la
contraratégie que nous console Parlement
peut se poser toutes les questions qu'il
faut après vous êtes d'accord avec moi
que la loi que vous venez de voter n'a
pas encore connu de produit ses effets
puisque nous sommes dans la première
année budgétaire de cette transformation
et encore une fois nous avons augmenté
de 4 mois la formation c'est remonter
d'un tiers nous avons augmenté de 50% la
formation continue mais je veux dire que
la police et la gendarmerie
contrairement à ce que j'ai entendu et
c'est tout à fait faux ne tire pas plus
qu'avant et oui les autres opérés
augmente bien plus qu'avant ça pose des
tas de questions les gens qui conduisent
sans permis les gens qui viennent de
cambrioler les gens qui ont de la drogue
les gens qui ont de l'alcool les gens
qui respectent plus aucune autorité
c'est tout à fait vrai il y a sans doute
beaucoup de raisons assez offertes mais
il n'est pas vrai quand j'ai lu et relu
et relu que nous augmenterions les
consignes de tir de les tirs les
consignes et donc les tirs sur les
refuses sur les reflets alors d'autres
questions ont été posées alors madame
Serge Regnault vous posez une question
difficile
je vais essayer de répondre non
seulement ce que je pense mais je crois
être la vérité
et je suis certain que le Président de
la République nous autorisera à rendre
public cette étude sociologique je veux
dire en dehors du travail des policiers
des gendarmes que des gens extérieurs
puissent regarder ce qui s'est passé
moi je n'y ai pas vu j'ai fait une
quinzaine de commissariats en 4 jours la
nuit et après ce que je fais quand je me
pose de garde c'est que je demande la
liste des personnes qui sont perdus et
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait jusqu'à
présent beaucoup dit que c'était des
gens pour violence à ta famille on peut
tous faire l'expérience vous êtes
parlementaire vous aider quand vous le
souhaitez bien évidemment ça va de la
République j'ai regardé et faites-le
dans vos commissariats de gendarmerie
qui sont ces gens oui il y a des gens
qui apparemment pourraient être issus
d'immigration mais il y a eu beaucoup de
Kevin et Matteo si je peux me permettre
il y en a eu aussi et l'explication
n'est pas n'est pas
l'explication seulement identitaire me
paraît très erronée
je ne veux pas ici dire je pense qu'une
explication
identitaire serait sereestropé et puis
surtout je pense que ce serait une
critique assez fort de ce qui s'est
apparemment parce que si je fais un
rapide calcul 17 ans de moyenne c'est à
dire qu'ils sont nés sous la présidence
de Jacques Chirac ça veut dire que
reprocher aujourd'hui imaginez d'Ichi
ferait immédiatement sur une question
migratoire
me paraît déjà trop tard madame la
sénatrice si jamais c'était votre
solution en revanche la question de
l'intégration et la réussite de
l'assimilation est une question
intéressante
et je crois que la posée simplement en
termes d'identitaire serait une réponse
trop facile mais encore une fois ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure il faut il faut
se poser sur les sur les sur les
questions
est-ce que une explication sociale est
la seule réponse je ne le crois pas
totalement non plus d'abord ce serait
une insulte extrêmement forte à tous
ceux qui issus des familles très
modestes
travaillent et respectent l'ordre et
c'est pas parce que on connaît des
situations très modestes qu'on attaque
des bibliothèques qu'on attaque des CCAS
on a attaqué des CCAS voilà chacun sait
ce que ça veut dire des postes dans des
quartiers populaires et vous savez très
concrètement moi dans ma ville ou dans
la ville de Reims que j'étais visité en
quartier populaire attaquer les deux
postes des deux quartiers populaires
c'est à dire que les minima sociaux qui
sont parfois critiqués c'est-à-dire des
mandats que toucheront pas les gens leur
propre famille donc l'explication ne
peut pas être que sociale étant issue
d'immigration par ma famille et étant
issu une famille modeste par ma famille
je pense qu'il y a une part de liberté
de chaque individu de se sortir de son
déterminisme et que ce travail de la
République de l'aider à sortir ce
déterminisme il peut y avoir des
réflexes identitaires en communautaire
il peut y avoir des réflexes de classes
sociales mais je crois que le principe
de la République c'est de ne pas
discriminer les gens soit alors que
social soit par leur classe d'origine
éthique je ne suis pas naïf madame la
sénatrice je dis juste que je ne veux
pas confondre les choses il me semble
j'ai toujours combattu les discours qui
consistaient à dire qu'il y avait des
gens qui intrinsèquement si j'ose dire
essentiellement au sens de l'essence
était près déterminé sinon on aurait du
mal à comprendre comment beaucoup
d'entre eux servent dans l'armée
française dans la police française moi
je sais bien c'est parce que vous avez
dit mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il
y a aussi beaucoup d'enfants ici de
l'immigration que je croise dans les
couloirs de la police nationale que je
croise à la Berry que je croise à la
gendarmerie nationale que je croise dans
les armées et je crois et je crois et je
crois que c'est du question plus
d'intégration
et d'actions que fait la République pour
les aider à s'intégrer de
responsabilisation des personnes
individuellement que de déterminisme
d'origine ethnique ou sociale
je veux dire ce monsieur Durand que je
pense que j'ai répondu sur la le refuge
opéré on pourra parler à l'envie et sans
doute de manière un peu plus calme que
j'ai été
en désapprobation du communiqué du
syndicat Alliance et que j'ai été dit
même sur une chaîne de grand écoute
puisque c'était au journal de télévisé
de TF1 que ce n'était pas mémo après moi
monsieur le centaure j'ai deux
réflexions personnelles la première
c'est que la liberté syndicale elle est
pour tout le monde
liberté syndicale elle est pour tout le
monde je ne corrige aucun communiqué
d'aucun syndicats bon oui encore heureux
mais on voudrait que je corrige et
communiquer du syndicat Alliance je ne
suis pas adhérent du syndicat Alliance
ni des autres syndicats par ailleurs et
je ce n'est pas moi de faire la police
de la pensée ils ont sorti à communiquer
il y a une discussion politique je crois
qu'il s'attendait à cette réaction
politique point j'ai dit aux
responsables d'alliance pour qui
personnellement j'ai le plus grand
respect comme pour tous les syndicats de
policiers qui font un travail très
compliqué très difficile et qui
défendent l'intérêt des fonctionnaires
de police que ça me paraissait pas les
mots que j'aurais utilisés dans le
contexte en plus dans lequel nous étions
point une fois que j'ai dit ça je veux
aussi dire par ailleurs
que beaucoup de policiers beaucoup de
gendarmes
tout en ayant peut-être un avis
identique celui du communiqué du
syndicat Alliance ou on considérant que
les politiques d'en font pas assez vous
considérons que ils subissent beaucoup
de difficultés ou considérant comme
dirait même incontrie elle a
parfaitement raison même si nous
augmentons cette rémunération qui sont
mal payés
beaucoup de policiers et de gendarmes
ont été
malgré leur opinion politique
philosophique ou religieuse totalement
au rendez-vous de ce qu'a demandé la
République moi j'ai pas eu un mouvement
de grève un mouvement de désapprobation
et encore une fois je le redire même si
il y a 10 enquêtes igpn iggn et il faut
qu'elles a jusqu'au bout avoir des
dizaines de milliers d'intervention pour
avoir 4000 interpellation dans un
contexte où les maisons brûlées ou on
envoyait le raid pour libérer des élus
dans des mairies on envoyait une GIGN
pour pouvoir arrêter des émeutiers des
types du GIGN que j'ai croisé
excusez-moi c'était que des garçons à
Torcy moi expliquer que dans des
communes où ils sont allés il y avait 50
et Métiers ils étaient 4 bon ils ont
arrêté ces personnes pour brûler une
mairie pour brûler une médiathèque moi
je veux leur dire que j'ai très bien
compris qu'ils avaient été au
rendez-vous de la République et qu'ils
avaient compris qu'on avait besoin d'eux
une fois que j'ai dit ça les syndicats
ils ont la liberté de dire ce qu'ils
souhaitent et vous avez la liberté bien
évidemment ce sénateur de critiquer ce
sujet
la
les milices que vous évoquez ont existé
à Angers et à Chambéry notamment
documenté parmi l'histoire de la taille
nous avons procédé à des interpellations
nous avons présenté ces personnes devant
la justice
nous verrons bien à quelle réponse
pénale ils auront je vais aussi dire que
des militants ultra gauche comme l'a dit
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois ont participé de façon
extrêmement rare mais quand même à des
attaques je pense qu'au quartier du
Mirail à Toulouse notamment tout au
début on va essayer de faire ce qu'on
appelle une convergence des luttes
ils n'ont pas réussi et je veux dire ici
que moins de 2 % des personnes que nous
avons appelé sont connues des services
de renseignement et à ma connaissance un
seul fichier
donc on voit bien qu'il y a pas eu de
convergence des luttes même si ça avait
été souhaité
donc oui les milices d'extrême droite
doivent être absolument combattues nous
regarderons d'ailleurs comment on peut
documenter d'éventuelles dissolution
s'il existait des groupements faibles
des associations on y travaille en ce
moment monsieur le sénateur et oui le
combat contre l'ultra gauche qui profite
et qui veut mettre bas notre système
républicain doit être également combattu
je veux dire par ailleurs que il y a eu
effectivement à Lorient manifestement
une mobilisation en dehors de tout cadre
bien sûr de certains militaires
j'aimerais remercie le ministère des
armées d'avoir ouvert une enquête sur ce
qui s'est passé à Lorient à notre
connaissance je peux être que d'accord
avec l'intervention de Madame l'herbier
il passe simplement parce que je suis
grand électeur du Nord monsieur le
monsieur président de la commission je
n'ai pas dit pour qui je voter je n'ai
pas dit pour qui je voter monsieur le
Président canner et j'ai remarqué qu'en
ce temps de campagne satoriale vous avez
dit du bien du ministre de l'Intérieur
et vous l'avez me citer je saurai m'en
souvenir je saurai mon souvenir
d'autres convergences je veux dire
qu'elle a je crois parfaitement raison
et que et que là aussi je serai assez
curieux de savoir et peut-être que
l'étude de commenter par le Président de
la République nous permettra d'y
répondre combien de ces adolescents ou
jeunes adultes
faisaient partie de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance ou en tout cas ont connu un
parcours parental extrêmement détérioré
peut-être que non
peut-être que on peut considérer vous le
connaissez bien ces sujets que lorsqu'on
connaît des difficultés extrêmement
fortes quand on est enfant on a tendance
à les reproduire Philippe Seguin a une
jolie phrase disait l'adulte est
toujours l'enfant qu'il était je pense
que c'est c'est vrai et d'où
l'importance des parents évidemment du
cadre familial sur les mortiers monsieur
sénateur bonhomme je pense avoir répondu
tout à l'heure aux questions
gouvernement il faut absolument les
manger cette législation qui nous permet
peut-être de réglementer bien sûr ce
travail de de poursuite et et d'action
et de ces on en reparlera le président
de la République nous avons dit
travailler
sur la question
de l'action et vous parler de l'action à
Lyon madame la sénatrice moi aussi c'est
une étude que j'ai demandé au ministère
de l'intérieur j'ai eu l'impression
confusément dans les remontées j'ai fait
5 nuits de suite dans les centres
opérationnels que la des villes qui
avait une caméra vidéo surveillance
et les villes qui permettaient à la
police nationale d'intervenir sur les
caméras vidéo surveillance je pense à la
ville de Lyon qui ne le permet pas
madame la sénatrice je crois qu'on a été
plus efficace que les villes qui
n'avaient pas de caméra vidéo sur
l'ombre ou qui n'ont pas permis la
police intervenir c'est un fait je suis
désolé de le dire c'est un fait donc je
crois que pour corroborer c'est fait
forcément confus et peut-être avec un
billet psychologique de ma part nous
avons aussi demandé de regarder arrêt
des émeutes travail de police judiciaire
et présence de caméra vidéoprotection
pour que la représentation nationale
puisqu'on a souvent ce débat puis savoir
ces éléments présents
à évoqué la question des caméras piétons
il a mille fois raison moi je salue le
travail qui a fait le ministre et le
premier skaz-neuve dans la loi qui est
parmi ces caméras piétons quand je suis
arrivé au ministère de l'Intérieur il y
avait 11000 caméras piétons il y en a
désormais 53000 et ils vont continuer à
augmenter je passerai monsieur Satan
durat connaît ça sur le fait que les
caméras piétons d’alors étaient pas très
performantes elle ne couvrait pas les
elle ne couvraient pas les vacances
enfin on essaye donc on a relancé le
marché on a équipé tout ça soit
désormais individualisées on sait quelle
caméra ce qui était pas le cas
auparavant appartient à qui et dans
quelles conditions demain on perd demain
c'est aujourd'hui puisqu'on le fait déjà
dans quelques commissariats grâce à la
loi sécurité globale que vous n'avez pas
voté mais c'est pas très grave mais le
président de la commission des lois et
la majorité l'ont voté mais je sais que
ce point aurait pu être partagé on va
pouvoir avoir le contenu des caméras en
direct également dans les centres
opérationnels
donc évidemment la consigne ministre de
l'intérieur comme pour le port du Rio et
pour les problèmes se durant il l'a vu
que j'ai rappelé à tous les effectifs
qui devaient évidemment le porter c'est
de porter ses caméras piétons oui comme
vous monsieur le Président le cananaire
j'étais extrêmement surpris que les
motards de la DOPC de les portent pas
je pensais au début à une faute de la
hiérarchie
ce n'est pas vrai pourquoi ils ne le
porte pas je me suis aperçu alors comme
quoi j'avoue bien volontiers une erreur
et j'aurais dû tel un maire tous les
jours dans sa dans les rues regardez ce
qui se passait dans sa ville parce que
les équipements des motards et pas que
de PC de tous les motards est-elle qui
ne permet pas de mettre le harnais qui
permet de mettre la caméra
c'est un problème technique bien
évidemment qu'on peut le résoudre bien
sûr qu'elle me tarde doivent porter leur
caméra piéton comme je suis ministre et
que je n'ai pas tendance à regarder en
dessous pour voir qui a sauté maxima
mais elle coule pas nous allons changer
ça j'ai donné comme consigne que d'ici
la fin de l'année évidemment tous les
motards police et gendarmerie puisque
c'est le cas partout y compris dans la
gendarmerie nationale quand ils ont leur
moto de protection parce qu'évidemment
quand on est moteur on peut tomber vous
connaissez ces difficultés c'est pas
n'importe quel métier c'est très
difficile d'être trop tard il puisse
porter évidemment leur caméra piéton
donc vous avez ainsi votre votre réponse
et je ne peux être que d'accord
pour terminer je crois alors il y a la
question de l'organisation puis la
question de Madame assassin la présente
à sa cible
moi Madame à présente assassin j'ai pas
de d'idéologie pour la police parce que
je veux c'est que ça fonctionne dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
pour avoir été maire d'une commune
importante qui connaît des difficultés
qui a été aussi durement touchée moi il
me semble que mon commissariat c'est des
policiers de proximité j'ai des BST et
il faut un travail de proximité ils
connaissent les noms des médiateurs des
habitants et ils sont présents dans leur
territoire
et que c'est pas le travail des
policiers que de faire médiateur social
parce que c'est un autre travail et
d'ailleurs on demande pas médiateur
social de faire de faire policier il me
semble que la police municipale madame
la Présidente c'est une forme de police
de proximité
et je suis toujours étonné quand il y a
des mères qui disent il faut davantage
de proximité quand ils ont sans 200 300
policiers municipaux je peux dire c'est
bizarre parce que c'est comme le travail
que doit faire aussi une police
municipale qui doit arrêter de demander
toujours à mon avis davantage de moyens
s'il n'est pas déjà capable et beaucoup
de fond mais très bien un travail de
proximité maintenant qu'il faille
augmenter les effectifs pour qu'il soit
plus
en présence et moi en intervention la
réponse est oui c'est ce que c'est de
faire pourquoi on crée plus d'effectifs
de police nationale c'est pour que y ait
de des policiers qui bien sûr fassent
des interpellations
et d'autres qui soient en lien de
présence de voie publique ce qu'on
appelle plus de bleu dans la rue et
c'est pas la façon dont on donne des
consignes madame la Présidente il faut
bien comprendre ça qui perdent permet de
passer une police soit une autre c'est
le juste le manque d'effectif structurel
global que nous avons qui ne permet pas
de répondre à tous les appels 17 ou à
tous les appels de la police judiciaire
ou à tous les appels d'interpellation
pour qu'il y ait des policiers de
proximité ou de présence qui puissent
eux à dire bonjour aux commerçants être
présent en bas des tours des quartiers
ou simplement discuter avec les élus
c'est pas une question de consigne
donnée parmi zata par des préfets c'est
juste qu'on a pas assez d'effectif au
moment où je vous parle dans les grandes
agglomérations notamment pour répondre à
toutes les interpellations du 17
ce serait intéressant d'ailleurs que je
puisse vous livrer des augmentations
crescendo parce que tout le monde
appelle le 17 désormais et on l'a vu
d'ailleurs ça sera familiale et c'est
très bien et la présence donc on a un
problème de RH dans la police nationale
à coup sûr et d'ailleurs on essaie de le
réparer peu à peu donc
je veux bien en discuter à l'envie
madame la Présidente mais vous savez moi
je suis toujours étonné de deux choses
deux petits faits comme dirait Stendhal
le premier c'est un reportage que j'ai
vu à la télévision et et
c'était très étonnant il y avait un
monsieur cagoulé qui parlait à une
chaîne d'information continue qui disait
ouais les policiers ils arrêtent pas de
nous contrôler et on fait rien on ne
fait que vendre du shit
alors évidemment si on a un rapport avec
la police qui consiste à pas contrôler
ceux qui vendent de la drogue on va voir
un problème parce que la police
proximité peut pas passer à côté et dire
tiens moi je suis proximité donc quand
je vois un fait je n'interviens pas
deuxièmement j'étais au commissariat de
Dreux
parmi les très nombreux déplacements
j'arrive à l'étage du commissariat de
Dreux et puis il y avait je viens pour
dire bonjour le procureur de la
République il vient me saluer
et à côté il y avait une policière qui
faisait l'audition un jeune durant 14-15
ans je crois sa maman et l'avocate et la
maman veut dire monsieur le ministre
c'est incroyable pourquoi on est là mon
fils n'a rien fait et là l'autorité
judiciaire appelle quand même devant le
ministre que ben si ils son enfant à 3h
du matin était dans les rues de rue et
se servait dans des commerces qui
étaient pillés et elle a répondu il a
rien fait il venait juste de prendre sa
servir parce que c'est pas lui qui a
cassé la vitre
donc je pense qu'il y a sans doute une
part d'amélioration du travail du
ministère d'intérieur je ne veux pas
sous-estimer ce propos mais il y a une
part de la population qui ne reconnaît
plus l'autorité du tout et il y a une
part de la population madame la
Présidente pardon de vous le dire qui
et parfois complice de sa progéniture
nous avons des témoignages de parents
qui se servent pendant ses émeutes j'ai
un témoignage de la police de Paris il y
a 48 heures qui m'explique ils sont
allés à interpeller un jeune mineur
responsable de d'avoir cassé un magasin
histoire aller chez lui le père n'est
jamais ne s'est jamais levé du fauteuil
où il regardait sa télévision et lorsque
les policiers lui ont dit qu'il venaient
pour interpeller ses enfants il a dit
lequel qu'est-ce qu'il a encore fait
sans jamais se lever sans jamais
éteindre la télévision quand vous avez
ce genre de témoignage de policiers vous
vous dites que on peut toujours
améliorer l'information la police
nationale mais peut-être qu'il y a aussi
une part pour la société
me semble-t-il que ne peut pas répondre
la population et puis enfin sur
l'organisation
je dis à madame la sénatrice que c'est
sans doute pas une organisation sauf si
je me fais des mentir par le travail
judiciaire évidemment donc sous toutes
réserve parce que c'est assez frais au
sens où nous l'entendons
au sens où cette organisé avec des gens
organisés avec du financement organisé
que c'était préparé c'était sans doute
spontané
donc le fait que les perquisitions
administratives de l'état d'urgence ne
m'ont pas parus évidents ça aurait été
une atteinte aux libertés publiques sans
pour autant en efficacité du travail de
la police bon je dis pas qu'il faut
jamais l'utiliser je dis jusque là j'ai
considéré que je n'avais pas besoin de
ça pour établir l'ordre
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que c'était
une organisation au sens
réseau du terme
et je crois que là les réseaux sociaux
sont très larges
interpellent dans leur effet mimétique
bien sûr la compétition
qui a été qui explique sans doute une
mobilisation de certaines villes
moyennes
qui n'existait pas en 2005
mais aussi par les messages qui se
passaient et vous savez je redire une
chose que j'ai déjà dit en commission
des lois je sais que les sénateurs sont
particulièrement attentifs aux libertés
publiques je voulais redire d'ailleurs
que Miss des libertés publiques c'est
moi le musée libertin Vivienne c'est de
garder ça mais la direction de liberté
publique c'est un ministère de
l'Intérieur
les écoutes téléphoniques à la papa ça
marche très peu désormais tout le monde
s'appelle sur WhatsApp sur telegram sur
signal sur les messageries ditescriptées
ou sur les réseaux sociaux type Facebook
snapchat Instagram le ministre de
l'Intérieur
n'a pas les moyens légaux vous le savez
très bien de regarder ces échanges de
formation là il peut le faire que dans
un cas très précis qui inca terroriste
que vous lui avez accordé donc je veux
dire aux Français qui reproche pourquoi
pourquoi ils interviennent pas je suis
habilis qui applique les lois de la
République je suis de pouvoir exécutif
une petite parcelle
je peux faire de la captation dite à
distance rentrer dans les téléphones
pour des sujets terroristes je suis très
contrôlé je demande des mises sur écoute
ou des
surveillances des réseaux sociaux qui
sont ensuite signés par trois autres
personnes et par une autorité une
strative indépendante que vous
additionnez d'ailleurs périodiquement
donc on ne fait pas ça la légère après
il y a de pouvoir judiciaire c'est un
autre sujet je ne peux pas demander
qu'on regarde Instagram Facebook
snapchat WhatsApp WhatsApp signal votre
téléphone
dans des cas de grandes violences
urbaines de délinquance de trafic de
drogue
donc je pense qu'il y a une question à
vous poser mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs si vous voulez
que la police et les moyens sous le
contrôle du juge et sous le contrôle des
autorités indépendantes
puissent casser les réseaux très
importants de trafic et notamment de
trafic de drogue
il va falloir bien un jour étudier la
possibilité que la police et la
gendarmerie et des yeux pour voir et des
oreilles pour écouter dans le cadre de
la législation et dans le cadre du
respect comme on l'a fait dans le cadre
des écoutes téléphoniques par exemple
et sinon pourquoi qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que on va se retrouver
dans la même situation qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas prévoir ce qui se passe on
ne peut pas savoir ce qui se passe et
c'est qu'au bout de 48 heures où on a
interpellé les personnes et on a ouvert
des enquêtes judiciaires et comme l'a
exprimé le garde des sceaux avec des
mots fleuris qu'on a pu
péter les comptes je crois que les
escaliers ils gardent des sauts dans un
langage clair
oui mais en judiciaire le judiciaire est
donc toujours la conséquence d'un fait
là vous me demandez à moi des comptes en
tant que ministre de l'Intérieur donc
permettez-moi de vous dire que tant que
nous resterons dans ce genre de
fonctionnement nous aurons des résultats
judiciaires mais après des faits si vous
voulez l'administratif comme vous le
permettant d'écouter téléphonique
classique si vous voulez faire avant
l'effet il faudra donner les pouvoirs un
jour à la police la gendarmerie encadrée
je sais que c'est une question très
compliquée et je ne veux pas ici faire
d'annonces particulières j'ai eu
l'occasion plusieurs fois à me se
présente commission de l'avoir dit en
trois ans que je vous fréquente et que
je viens de dire dans votre mission donc
il y a eu organisation au sens réseau
moderne du terme
avec sans doute des mots du genre on va
d'abord casser les caméras de
vidéoprotection on va se coordonner pour
attaquer à la mairie machin bah non il y
a le raid donc du coup on va aller au
commerce bidule c'est ça l'organisation
c'est une organisation de de voler de
moineau c'est pas une organisation au
sens criminel du thème du terme pardon
peut-être que demain ça évoluera ça je
ne sais pas mais cette organisation elle
a été très difficile dans la mesure où
les services de pays gendarmerie ne
peuvent pas c'est pas qu'ils ne peuvent
pas en technique mais ne peuvent pas au
sens légal regardez ce qui se passe sur
ces réseaux que nous utilisons tous et
si nous notamment vous les utilisez pour
votre vie quotidienne vous imaginez que
ceux qui ont des choses à se reprocher
ils utilisent pour d'autres raisons et
donc je soumis à votre sagacité cette
réflexion parce que je crois que ça
explique bien des choses aussi dans le
fonctionnement de ces émeutes
délinquantes
et c'est pour toute ces explications la
réponse aux questions sans doute que
nous aurons l'occasion d'en redébattre
et que lorsque notamment vous aurez
d'autres éléments
supplémentaires mais un tout hypothèse
au moment de lever cette réunion je
voudrais redire notre entier soutien et
notre volonté aussi d'aller beaucoup
plus loin et d'aller beaucoup plus loin
surtout sur l'analyse de fond et la
vérité des situations pour tenter
d'apporter une réponse qui s'opérait
évidemment